so what do you make of silk roast the
shadow crew started something that today
you can call dark net and dark net
markets
so these markets that operate that trade
uh trade things everything from child
pornography to drugs to
i mean what else
everything what are the dark things that
humans want to do that they don't want
anyone to know about all of those things
um
so
can you maybe
tell me you know what let's just even
step back what is the dark net how big
is it so what happens there let's let's
backtrack a little bit more before we
get to that all right um what shadow
crew
did
other than
you know dealing in all these
stolen wares
what shadow crew did that's really
important remember those three
necessities that i talked about
but the important thing is is it
established trust among criminals all
right because that's a necessity you
have to be able to trust
who you're dealing with because you have
to deal with somebody you have to
all right so how do you know you're not
dealing with a cop how do you know
you're dealing with somebody that's
skilled how you know you're going to
deal with somebody that's not going to
rip you off you have to be able to trust
that individual
the shadow crew provided that trust
mechanism for criminals you had that
communication channel the forums where
you could reference conversations weeks
months old take part and learn from
those conversations
you had vouching systems and review
systems in place escrow systems in place
you had you could knew by looking at
someone's screen name
if you could trust the individual
network with the individual all right
and that community
of just humans
provided
that backbone of trust and that's that's
really interesting when you think about
it you it you had the trust that was
there but you also had this
almost this instantaneous
information that was available about the
community or about cyber crime at large
and that's that's still in play today
all right so when
that that was the way things were until
a couple of things happened and one was
cryptocurrency
the other one was
the tour browser the dark web now i was
working with a secret service ripping
the secret service off
when tor comes into play all right so we
got we got a memo in one day and it was
talking about the tour browser and it
was like we really need to be careful
with this this is going to be problem
and so we all fired up the tor browser
and it turns out it was this was 2005
early 6.
turns out it was completely unusable
could not use it at all simply because
no one was using it and it was extremely
slow so so for people don't know tor
browser is a way to be completely
anonymous as long as you properly know
how to use it right huge caveat yeah all
right so developed by the united states
navy
and they developed this
oh yeah it wasn't the hackers that
interest u.s navy
to this day the number one funder of
tour
military
to this day
all right interesting i mean the same i
guess with the internet the the origins
are
uh so that operatives
could communicate with each other
without being identified all right
that then goes open source they release
it eff comes in starts sponsoring
everything else like that
the next idea was well you know people
get around their country's firewalls
whistleblowers can use it things like
that well someone forgot to mention that
the first adoptees of tech
if you can use it to launder money or
remain anonymous
are criminals
so criminals start to use the damn thing
all right
so along the same time we get well a few
years later we get satoshi nakamoto pops
up with his ideas for bitcoin
and then ross albrecht runs with it ross
albert decides he's going to start up
silk road so initially the people who
were using tor which later is the dark
web
people are using tor or just
talking with each other visiting
websites communicating like that someone
figured out hey man we could host
websites
on this thing and they have a lot of
trouble finding the box
so that
is the advent of
silk road all of a sudden ross obrecht
has this idea that he's going to change
the world
by becoming the largest drug dealer on
the planet
so he opens up the silk road and the
only payment instrument he allows
is bitcoin
so if those people out there are
wondering why bitcoin is going at what
44k today
yeah yeah it starts by the time this is
out it could be a hundred thousand or
ten thousand absolutely we'll see who
knows
if it's ten thousand i'm going to buy
some
which is a hilarious statement to make
because that statement would be
ridiculously wrong like five years ago
right
people 100 years from now i'll be
laughing wait it was that low
so he only accepts bitcoin and that's of
course the the initial use case of
crypto is no one wants to admit it today
but the initial use case is we're going
to buy a bunch of pot
we need somebody we need a way to pay
for it
so that's that's what happens uh ross
it's it's really interesting to me if
you um
if you look at motivations of cyber
criminals
the motivations are status
cash
ideology all right
my guys all cash across the board all
cash
ross is ideology
he really believed he was going to
change the world he really didn't i've
been fortunate
i uh i actually know the guy who ran
silk road too
and uh have talked to the kid
everything else and uh i will tell you
that those those guys who
are motivated by ideology they are a
completely different breed
they really are it's not you know the
cash guy it's it's it's low-hanging
fruit the the ease of of
it's hard to stop committing crime
but it's much easier for a
cash-motivated individual to stop than
it is that ideology guy
that silk road 2 guy he's still got it
you know he's not breaking the law but
you can see it's like
he wants to
he wants to so it's it's uh
that's fascinating that i i mean the
worst atrocities in human history are
committed
with people that operate under ideology
all the other motivations are much
weaker but you know you think about it
with ross i mean
very bright guy
very bright guy
but think about the amount of cognitive
dissonance that the guy's got
that he thinks he's going to change the
world
by running a drug
site i mean it
certainly i mean
could he have changed the world yeah
could he have done it like that
probably not
well i could steal man those arguments i
said listen to quite a few
uh libertarians and you can push that to
anarchists and
you know there's a lot of people that
argue um
so i actually talked to uh to fac to a
professor colombia who actually argues
that all drugs should be legalized and
not at a philosophical level political
level but
the fact that um all the negative
consequences of drugs that people talk
about
are actually
have to do with other factors in your
life i would agree with that and so
that's a okay but that's more like a
argument about
negative aspects of drugs i think the
ideology comes in where it's like well
nobody should tell you what to do you
should be
you should have the responsibility of
your own actions like uh
um
the government or any other institution
shouldn't be
the uh
the rule setters the constraints for how
you live your life and so that i could i
could see that argument being made and
ultimately if you
uh like
create an open market for drugs how that
could build a better society it might
break down the outdated
the corrupt the bureaucratic
institutions i mean you can make that
you can make that there's an argument
and let's be fair i want to be fair with
it i mean
could did he change the world
we do have this whole thing called
cryptocurrency yeah in the long arc of
history perhaps yeah we do have that
yeah
so that's a biggie so
and that might have been for it to take
hold in society maybe the darker parts
of society at first maybe that was
necessary
you